McCarthy initially said well what we
really need to do is pass a continuing
resolution again which you know this
country has been governed by continuing
resolution or Omnibus since the mid 90s
I know Omnibus is when you pack a bunch
of things into one bill and then get
someone but what's the continuing
resolution A continuing resolution is
however things are being funded right
now just fund them the same way next
year with increases for you know
inflation cost of living
so so just keep doing the everything the
way it's always been done is the
definition of a continuing resolution I
do not believe that is a serious and
responsible way to govern and I believe
the reason we have a 32 trillion dollar
debt is because we have governed this
way since the mid 90s so McCarthy wanted
to do that and say well that'll just buy
us time and we'll just do a continuing
resolution for a little bit but don't
worry after that we'll really get our
single subject spending bills in order
I've heard the same for seven
years I've been here and it's always the
same rhythm